LUCAS MOREL: Hi.
I'm Lucas Morel, the John
K. Boardman junior professor
of politics and
head of the Politics
Department at Washington
and Lee University
in Lexington, Virginia.
I'm also a visiting
teaching fellow
at the Kirby Center, the School
of Government in Washington,
DC, for Hillsdale College.
Welcome to this symposium
on race in America.
I'll be speaking today on
a colorblind constitution.
Abraham Lincoln once said
that the central idea
of American public opinion,
from the beginning,
was the equality of men.
The problems, of
course, arose when
the idea was undermined
by the continued practice
of racial slavery
as it was defended,
no longer as a necessary
evil, but as a positive good,
if you can believe it-- good
for the master and the slave.
Even though the
defenders of slavery
were defeated in the
Civil War, white supremacy
still reigned
throughout the South
well into the 20th century.
And so a nation that
began as the first
in human history devoted
to the self-evident truth
that all men are created equal
still wrestles with the role
that race should or should
not play in government policy.
Put simply, should
Americans govern themselves
in a colorblind fashion when
it comes to the rule of law,
or should we use race to try
to eliminate the lingering
effects of racial
slavery and segregation?
Put simply, should
Americans govern themselves
in a colorblind fashion when
it comes to the rule of law,
or should we use race
to try to eliminate
the lingering effects--
the legacy, as they say--
of racial slavery
and segregation?
One of the greatest American
orators of the 19th century,
this gentleman, an escaped
slave and abolitionist orator
Frederick Douglass,
began his public career
criticizing the United
States Constitution
as a pro-slavery document.
Douglass asked,
what country have I?
The institutions of this
country do not know me.
They do not recognize
me as a man.
And so he concluded, I
have no love for America.
To his credit, and this
country's, he did not
hold that position for long.
He eventually claimed
America as his country,
calling the principles of the
Declaration of Independence
saving principles, and
the Constitution no longer
as pro-slavery but a
glorious liberty document.
He found that reading
the Constitution the way
his former mentor,
William Lloyd Garrison,
read it, as a
pro-slavery document,
contradicted its
preamble and gave
short shrift to the many levers
of freedom found therein.
He also noticed that the
Constitution actually never
mentioned the word "slave"
or "slavery" or "race,"
and it permitted the
Congress to actually ban
the importation of
slaves as early as 1808,
which they actually did.
He said, therefore, that it
leans to freedom, not slavery,
and looked to the
abolition of slavery
rather than its perpetuity.
Planting his political identity
firmly in his citizenship,
it led this former slave,
who had every reason
to hate America, to become
one of her greatest defenders.
On the question of race
in the Constitution,
Frederick Douglass was clear.
Quote, "Color should not be
the criterion of rights,"
end quote.
He also said, "I
know of no rights
of race superior to the
rights of humanity."
When asked what he would do if
he were president of the United
States, after he stopped
laughing because that was
absurd at that time-- he
knew it would never happen--
he replied, I would secure to
every citizen of the United
States, without
regard to color or sex
or religion or race, equal
protection of the laws.
If all men are created
equal, then their government
should protect them
equally, secure
what each member of
the political community
possesses equally, namely,
their natural rights.
Douglass's plain reading
of the Constitution
and the Declaration
of Independence
led him to conclude that
Blacks should not be
made an exception in the law.
This would reinforce
the stereotype
of racial inferiority and
undermine the central idea
that all men are created equal.
Douglass always
considered the impact
that public policy would have
on how whites treated and viewed
Black Americans.
And therefore, he didn't
favor any government practice
that would relieve Black
Americans of any duty
or responsibility
that was expected
of all other Americans.
"We do not solicit
unusual favor," he said,
"but will be content with
rough handed fair play."
He went on to add, "We are
neither lame or blind that we
should seek to throw
off the responsibility
of our own existence
or to cast ourselves
upon public charity
for support."
But as much as Douglass did to
promote the elevation of Blacks
in America, he
actually was not a fan
of what we would
today call race pride.
He called it a false
foundation and a positive evil.
He proclaimed it the very
thing we're fighting against.
For most of American
history, Black Americans
wanted nothing to do with the
color line that separated them
from the rest of the
American population.
He wrote that it was our
enemies who sought to, quote,
"deepen and widen the
line of separation
between the white and colored
people of this country."
Given that Blacks were
a numerical minority
in the United States,
racial solidarity
was never the key to gaining
greater security and protection
of their civil and
political rights.
His argument against
race pride led
him to criticize what he called
complexional institutions.
Over a decade before Lincoln
was elected president,
Douglass argued, quote, that
"all distinctions founded
on complexion ought to
be repealed, repudiated,
and forever abolished.
Every right,
privilege, and immunity
now enjoyed by the white man
ought to be as freely granted
to the man of color."
He thought that, for example,
colored conventions, as they
called it then,
colored exhibitions,
colored associations
and institutions--
he said these are hindrances
rather than helps in achieving
a higher and better
estimation for the Black man
in the public mind.
His concern for the impact of
public policy on public opinion
led him to argue against any
recognition of race or color
when it came to
government policy.
It's safe to say
that Douglass was not
a practitioner of
identity politics.
So have the American people ever
adopted Douglass's clear belief
in a colorblind Constitution?
After the 14th Amendment was
ratified just a few years
after the end of the Civil
War, the Supreme Court
began to decide cases involving
equal treatment under the law.
One of the key clauses
of the 14th Amendment
requires that no state
shall, quote, "deny
to any person within
its jurisdiction
the equal protection of
the laws," end quote.
This would seem to
ban any government
use of racial classifications.
But unlike Douglass,
who did not believe
race should be the measure of
anyone's constitutional rights,
to this day, the
Supreme Court has never
adopted or interpreted
the Constitution to be
a colorblind Constitution.
Instead, it has reserved
to itself the authority
to decide when government
use of race is constitutional
and when it is not.
Ironically, it was a
lone dissenting opinion
that introduced the concept
of a colorblind Constitution.
However, that dissenting
justice was outnumbered
by 7 justices who interpreted
the Constitution to permit
government use of race as long
as it was done in, as they
call it, a reasonable fashion.
What was later known as the
rational basis test permitted
large discretion on the
part of state governments
to employ racial classifications
to promote the peace, safety,
and comfort of the community.
That case was
Plessy v. Ferguson,
an 1896 ruling that gave us the
notion that separate but equal
was all right.
It was an acceptable measure
of whether one's race was
being used in a constitutional
way by state government.
This pernicious standard was
precedent for subsequent cases
until the landmark decision
in Brown v. Board of Education
of Topeka, Kansas in 1954.
It ruled unanimously that racial
segregation of public schools
deprives students of,
quote, "the equal protection
of the laws guaranteed by the
14th Amendment," end quote.
The NAACP, the National
Association for the Advancement
of Colored People, they provided
the lead group of attorneys
in these cases.
Their in-house legal defense
fund, known as The Fund,
had for decades not attacked
segregation laws directly,
but had argued, and
argued successfully,
that segregation
was unconstitutional
because it did not apply equally
to citizens of all races.
They adopted this
strategy early on because
of the precedent of
separate but equal,
the separate but equal doctrine
established in the 1896 case
of Plessy v. Ferguson.
So the NAACP contested
legal segregation
not by arguing that it
itself was unconstitutional,
but only if they separated
citizens according
to race in an unequal way.
The idea was to make
segregation too expensive,
especially for Southern state
governments to maintain.
If a state provided a public
park, a library, a pool, a golf
course, but only did
so-- it was public,
but only did so for whites, but
it didn't provide one equally
for Black citizens,
or they provided
one of inferior quality,
the NAACP would say, ah,
this violates the 14th
Amendment which says, again,
nor shall any state deny to any
person within its jurisdiction
the equal protection
of the laws.
In case after case, in the
first half of the 20th century,
the NAACP won court
case after court case
in the highest Court in the
land using this strategy,
showing that racial
segregation was never applied--
or not applied equally.
And it forced states to
provide equal accommodations
or, if they lacked the
funds, to eliminate
the segregated
facility altogether.
Well, the problem was that after
a while, Southern states that
had been segregating
but could not
afford to do so
on an equal basis,
they just decided to
close it all down,
close the public facility
rather than desegregate them
or provide an equivalent
one for Black citizens.
More importantly, in
terms of the jurisprudence
that the NAACP was pursuing
here, with each victory,
they were actually
reinforcing legal segregation
by reinforcing the precedent
of separate but equal
that was established
way back in 1896.
So by the 1940s, the
Legal Defense Fund finally
decided to attack
segregation head on,
and they invited the Supreme
Court to overturn its decision
in Plessy.
Now, this is a risky--
or was a risky strategy,
given how much the
high Court likes
to stick to previous decisions.
They don't like to admit
that they were ever wrong,
especially precedents that had
been on the books for so long.
In all four lower
court cases dealing
with segregated
schools, the courts
had followed the Plessy
doctrine of separate but equal.
They ruled that if the
conditions of the schools
were basically equal,
the Constitution was not
violated even if the
educational outcomes,
the results of that segregated
education, were unequal.
Why were the lower courts
so focused on the inputs--
for example,
buildings, curricula,
qualifications of the
teachers, their salaries--
rather than the
effect that segregated
or separate but equal conditions
were having on children?
For this, we have to go back
to the court's reasoning
in Plessy.
So some quick facts
about the Plessy case.
Homer Plessy was 7/8 Caucasian
and 1/8 African blood,
as the testimony said, though
the African-ness, if you will,
was not discernible.
You couldn't tell by
looking at Homer Plessy
that he was part Black.
He deliberately rode
in a railroad car
in Louisiana that
was only traveling
within the state of Louisiana.
He deliberately rode in a
car for white passengers
and actually had to tip
the conductor to the fact
that, oh, by the
way, I'm 1/8 Black.
So this was a contrived case.
He did this deliberately
so that this
could be thrown into court.
So Homer Plessy, a local
citizen's committee,
actually worked
with the railroads
because they thought it
was expensive to segregate.
They didn't want this either.
So they worked to try to
get this case to the Supreme
Court, which they did.
You have to remember,
at this time,
even though he was 1/8
Black, we were operating--
this country was
operating under what's
known as the one drop rule.
So it didn't matter
how Caucasian you were.
If you had one drop of
a particular other race
or ethnicity, that's
what they counted you as.
And you can trace this
back-- good grief,
Florida had a one drop rule all
the way back dating to 1866.
An important part
of the Plessy case
was the text of the
1890 Louisiana statute
that required separate
railway carriages for whites
and what they called
the colored race.
And this is what the text
says, that all railway
companies carrying passengers
in their coaches in this state
shall provide equal but
separate accommodations
for the white and colored
races by providing
two or more passenger coaches
for each passenger train
or by dividing the passenger
coaches by a partition
so as to secure
equal accommodations.
And it added-- and this
is very important--
no person or persons shall
be admitted to occupy seats
in coaches other than the ones
assigned to them on account
of the race they belong to.
Justice Brown interpreted
the Equal Protection
clause of the 14th
Amendment, quote,
"to enforce the absolute
equality of the two races
before the law," end quote.
However, he read this
to mandate equality
of treatment, not
equality of outcome
or social or public perception.
Just because whites must
sit in this railway carriage
and Blacks must sit in
that railway carriage,
he says this does not impose
a badge of inferiority
on either race.
Moreover, state
legislatures, he said,
had long been
allowed to separate
the races in public venues
as part of their traditional
what is known as police powers.
Justice Brown gives
the example, actually,
of segregated schools,
even in the states where
the rights of Blacks
had been, quote,
"most earnestly
enforced," end quote.
So this was a
longstanding practice.
Justice Brown gets to
the crux of the issue
when he says the case comes
down to whether the statute
of Louisiana is a
reasonable regulation.
His answer?
There must necessarily
be a large discretion
on the part of the
legislature, which
he argues is at liberty
to act with reference
to established usages, customs,
and traditions of the people,
and with a view to the
promotion of their comfort
and the preservation of the
public peace and good order.
Now, all of this, of
course, was a euphemism
for maintaining the
status quo, which,
of course, was white supremacy.
Given this practice, the
Court concluded that, quote,
"we cannot say that a law which
authorizes or even requires
the separation of the two
races in public conveyances is
unreasonable or more obnoxious
to the 14th Amendment than
the acts of Congress requiring
separate schools for colored
children in the
District of Columbia,
the constitutionality of which
does not seem to have been
questioned, or the corresponding
acts of state legislatures,"
end quote.
So this reasonableness
standard, what we now
call the rational
basis test, it actually
is the lowest threshold
for state action
to be considered constitutional
or unconstitutional, especially
under the 14th Amendment's
Equal Protection Clause.
So the court therefore allows
large discretion by the states
if they employ, at that time and
for decades, racial segregation
when regulating public
interaction between the races.
But what if racial segregation
produces a perception
that one race is
inferior to another,
a badge of inferiority?
Justice Brown addresses
this directly in a passage
that Chief Justice
Earl Warren will later
reject to arrive at the
opposite conclusion.
And this is 60 years
later in the Brown case.
So here's what the
Plessy Court concluded.
We consider the
underlying fallacy
of the plaintiff's argument
to consist in the assumption
that the enforced
separation of the two races
stamps the colored race
with a badge of inferiority.
If this be so, it
is not by reason
of anything found in the act
or the statute, but solely
because the colored race
chooses to put that construction
or that interpretation upon it.
In other words, any
feeling of inferiority
as a result of
racial segregation
is not the product
of government policy
as long as that racial
policy is equally applied.
The Court's Separate but Equal
doctrine does not actually
make any citizen inferior.
Therefore, if someone
does feel inferior
because of a racial
classification,
that's because
that person chooses
to interpret it that way.
In the one dissenting opinion,
the opinion of Justice John
Marshall Harlan, he thinks that
this reading of the statute
is absurd.
Everyone knows that this law
and other segregation laws
are intended to maintain
a legal, or at least
a social hierarchy of
whites over Blacks.
He also doesn't think courts,
especially the Supreme Court,
should inquire into the
so-called reasonableness
or wisdom of state legislatures.
The only question the Supreme
Court should try to answer,
he thought, was, does
the state law comport
with the Constitution?
And in this case, it's the
Equal Protection Clause
of the 14th Amendment.
In his mind, the Court
recognizes no caste or superior
ruling class of citizens.
He then cited a concept that
was actually first presented
at oral argument by the lead
attorney for Homer Plessy,
and that was a guy
named Albion Tourgee.
At oral argument,
he observed, quote,
"If justice is pictured
blind, then the law, at least,
should be colorblind."
Here's how Justice Harlan
put it in his dissent.
"Our Constitution is colorblind
and neither knows nor tolerates
classes among citizens.
In respect of civil
rights, all citizens
are equal before the law."
He added, "The law
regards man as man
and takes no account
of his surroundings
or of his color when his
civil rights are guaranteed
by the supreme law of the land."
So given so many subsequent
cases that relied upon Plessy
as precedent, how did
the Warren court in 1954
rule unanimously to reject the
separate but equal doctrine?
In its short-- I think
it's nine pages--
plainly written ruling, the
new Chief Justice, Justice Earl
Warren, argued that Americans
in the mid 20th century
now lived in a different world
than that of the 1896 Plessy
Court.
Most importantly, education
was now a leading function
of state government.
It was now compulsory, supported
by a substantial budget,
and had become, as Warren
put it, the very foundation
of good citizenship.
So if the state became the
educator of its citizens,
then it was
responsible, according
to Warren, not just for
the educational inputs
but for what those
inputs produced,
the educational outcomes.
Such an opportunity,
Earl Warren said,
where the state has
undertaken to provide it,
is a right which must
be made available to all
on equal terms.
To get around the Plessy
doctrine of separate but equal,
Chief Justice Warren leaned
on more recent precedents--
Sweatt v. Painter and
McLaurin v. Oklahoma, 1950--
to include what he called
intangible considerations
in the educational
process, not just inputs,
material ones like buildings
or teacher qualifications,
things you could measure, but
also the learning environment
and-- this is key--
what that environment
produced, the results.
As he put it, we
must look instead
to the effect of segregation--
segregation itself, its
effect on public education.
He concluded that
to separate children
from others of similar age and
qualifications solely because
of their race generates
a feeling of inferiority
as to their status
in the community that
may affect their hearts and
minds in a way unlikely ever
to be undone.
So when governments segregate
children according to race
and this separation produces
feelings of inferiority,
then government is now
responsible for that outcome.
It's not simply an
interpretation or construction
that children choose to
put on their racially
segregated school.
The Court ruled that in the
field of public education,
the doctrine of separate
but equal has no place.
Separate educational facilities
are inherently unequal.
Now, few Court observers
disputed the decision--
the result in this case.
But many questioned the
reasoning, especially
its reliance upon
psychological tests
to determine the effects
of racial segregation
upon segregated students.
To decide if the Constitution
was violated by a government
use of race on the basis
of feelings generated
seemed like a dubious
basis for determining
if a person's rights under the
Constitution were infringed.
Think about it.
What if a segregated
school didn't generate
a feeling of inferiority?
Would there be no violation
of the Equal Protection
Clause of the 14th Amendment?
And if not, did Brown
actually overturn Plessy?
Now, if Brown decided
that government could not
pay attention to race,
couldn't separate
students on the
basis of race in K
through 12 schools, public
schools, the second case
involving education ruled
that government could use race
in higher education, not
to separate but to promote
diversity, what they call the
educational benefits that flow
from a racially
diverse student body.
So we now shift our
discussion of government use
of racial classifications from
segregation or desegregation,
to the policy known today
as affirmative action.
It should go without
saying that using race
in a constitutional way means
you're not operating according
to a colorblind Constitution.
We'll see how the
Supreme Court justifies
this under the 14th Amendment's
Equal Protection Clause.
The key case is actually
two cases in 2003
involving the University
of Michigan, their law
school and their
undergraduate university.
They are the cases of Grutter
v. Bollinger and Gratz
v. Bollinger, respectively.
Now, the Supreme Court
upheld affirmative action
as it was practiced
in the law school,
but it rejected
affirmative action
that operated differently at
the undergraduate university.
The key precedent for
Justice Sandra Day O'Connor,
who took all the Supreme Court
affirmative action cases when
she was on the court--
her key precedent was a case
that had been on the books
for 25 years, the 1978
case of Regents v. Bakke.
Unlike the Brown
decision, which only
relied on the 14th
Amendment back in 1954,
O'Connor's opinion drew from two
provisions of the Constitution,
and in this she was
following Justice Powell
in Bakke-- the Equal Protection
Clause of the 14th Amendment
for sure, but also,
because it dealt
with higher education,
the Free Speech
Clause of the First Amendment.
Reasonableness or the
Rational Basis Test
was the prevailing
Court standard
until about World War II,
when two cases dealing
with Japanese internment,
the Hirabayashi case in 1943
and the Korematsu case of 1944--
these led the Court to adopt
a new, more rigorous measure
of constitutionality
when it came to race.
Racial classifications
by government
were now considered by the
Court immediately suspect.
They weren't categorically
unconstitutional.
They've never ruled that.
But they were immediately
suspect and subject to,
as the Court put it,
the most rigid scrutiny.
So they're moving
off of reasonableness
and ratcheting it up a bit.
This is now known as the
strict scrutiny test,
and it's a test that has
two prongs, both of which
have to pass in order for
a government use of race
to be considered constitutional.
Number one, it has to serve
a compelling state interest.
It has to be a priority
of the state government.
And that also includes the
federal government now.
Secondly, it has to
be narrowly tailored
to meet that state interest.
So you have a constitutionally
permissible end
that you're looking for, and
a corresponding constitutional
means to securing that
end if you're using race.
So at the University
of Michigan,
affirmative action
was used, again,
one way at the law
school and another way
at the undergraduate university.
The difference between
the two policies
produced the different
outcomes, as O'Connor, and then
Rehnquist in the Gratz case,
applied strict scrutiny.
So what were they doing
at the law school?
They were looking at students
according to race, especially
those that they considered
underrepresented minorities.
We'll use the acronym URM.
So they would favor
URMs to produce
what they called a critical mass
or meaningful representation
of Blacks, Hispanics,
and Native Americans.
And if you listen to
the oral arguments--
I remember being on the
Interstate 66 on my way to DC
and actually listening.
I think this was one
of the first court
cases where they actually--
I think this was on
NPR-- they actually
let you listen to what
was actually being said.
The Michigan attorney
was fantastic.
Whatever they paid her,
they should have given her
a raise, because Scalia and
the conservative justices
were leaning in on her.
They were trying to see if
they could say that Michigan
was employing a quota.
And they said,
hmm, critical mass.
Could you define
critical mass for us?
And she said, yeah--
meaningful
representation of URMs.
And they were like, heh heh heh!
What's meaningful
representation?
So if she used an absolute
number or a fixed percentage
or a narrow band that
they were looking for,
they would have lost.
Even the liberals on the
court would have said,
you can't do that.
You know what she did?
She just said, critical mass.
She just bounced back
and forth-- critical
mass, meaningful
representation--
until the justices gave up.
So critical mass.
Second, the state
of Michigan argued
that it had a
compelling interest
to diversify the
student body in order
to enhance the education
of its law students.
So how do you get
educational diversity,
free exchange of ideas?
You can use race to
help promote that.
Lastly, it claimed that its
pursuit of a critical mass
was not a quota, which
had been disallowed
in the precedent of
Bakke 25 years earlier.
Now, because the case dealt
with higher education, colleges
and grad schools,
like law schools--
Justice O'Connor drew from
Powell's Bakke opinion
to argue that not one, but
two constitutional provisions,
as I mentioned earlier, needed
to be balanced or reconciled
to determine if the law school's
use of race was justified.
Now, we've got the Equal
Protection Clause, which
I'm sure you're tired
of me mentioning,
but they're all over it.
You have, on the one hand,
the Equal Protection Clause
of the 14th Amendment.
But then you also have the First
Amendment's Free Speech Clause.
Now why?
Courts have long treated
colleges and universities
as a special niche in
constitutional adjudication.
The nature of
education, they believe,
requires academic freedom.
And so what do they say?
They respected the university's
need, the law school
in this case, to
determine how best
to promote the exchange of ideas
necessary for the education
of their students.
If racial diversity could
help in this regard,
the Court was not
going to second guess.
This is important.
They were going to
defer to Michigan's
educational autonomy,
as they called it,
as it pursued what
they considered
to be a compelling state
interest, even though you've
got this constitutional
requirement that no state shall
deny to any person the equal
protection of the laws.
So in satisfying the first prong
of the Strict Scrutiny Test,
let me make a few observations
about O'Connor's reasoning.
First, she presumes--
and she calls it
this-- she presumes good faith
on the part of the university
when it claims
that hey, hey, hey,
we're only using race to
promote this educational end.
Now, what's interesting
about this--
if the Court is deferring
to them, if you will,
granting them large
discretion in its use of race,
doesn't that sound an awful lot
like Justice Brown's reasoning
in Plessy?
Second, because the
Bakke precedent from 1978
ruled that redressing
historical wrongs--
the thing that you would
think affirmative action
would be all about--
Justice Powell said, no.
You can't claim that your
specific affirmative action
policy is going to
redress or provide
a remedy for
historical harms that
were done to racial minorities.
So he actually said, you can't
justify racial classifications
by saying we're trying
to repair the damage
of previous discrimination.
The only purpose for Powell,
and O'Connor borrowed this--
the only purpose that
passed constitutional muster
was racial diversity
as a means of promoting
educational diversity.
What's curious here
is Michigan provides
a counterintuitive explanation
for its promotion of diversity.
Here it is.
They argued that they
needed to include
more underrepresented minorities
to break down stereotypes.
You don't want to have a token
Native American or Black person
or Hispanic in class,
because otherwise,
the majority white student
body would think, oh, yeah,
that's the way all Blacks think.
In short, you see what they did?
Affirmative action
is justified not
because it helps
racial minorities
but because it helps
the white kids.
That's an interesting
turn of events.
What O'Connor called
effective participation
she saw was promoted
by a law school that
enrolled a sufficient number--
meaningful
representation-- of URMs.
This showed, in her mind,
the path of leadership
being visibly open to talented
and qualified individuals
of every race and ethnicity.
And although O'Connor
claimed that race was not
to be understood as a
proxy for a specific way
that all members of
that race thought,
a critical mass of URMs
lets the law school
demonstrate visibly
that it is training
a diverse group of
attorneys and therefore
leading to the enhancement
of the integrity
and trustworthiness of those
who will eventually assume roles
of leadership in the nation.
Now, satisfied the first
prong of strict scrutiny.
What about that
narrowly tailored part?
We're moving from ends to means.
The 14th Amendment
protects, and O'Connor
is a stickler for this--
it protects individual
persons, not groups.
Therefore, affirmative
action that is constitutional
must ensure what
O'Connor, again drawing
from the Bakke
opinion of Powell,
called individualized
consideration.
Any policy that amounts to
a racial quota-- we're just
going to set aside a certain
number of seats or a dual track
admission system or any other
sort of mechanistic treatment
of applicants-- doesn't
treat each applicant
as an individual person
and therefore, in her mind,
would violate the Equal
Protection Clause.
While race can act as a plus,
it cannot be what she called
the defining feature of
a person's application.
O'Connor's majority opinion
in Grutter v. Bollinger
was a split decision, five
supporting affirmative action
at the law school and
four arguing to reject it.
That's a pretty tight,
pretty close decision.
So this made, though,
Grutter stronger than Bakke,
because that Bakke precedent
was peculiar in the sense
that Powell had an opinion
that no other justice joined.
You're like, well, how
could that be the precedent?
Well, four justices agreed
with part of Powell's decision
or reasoning, and
four other justices
agreed with a different part.
And that's how Powell's
opinion became the precedent
even though it wasn't
technically a majority opinion.
Then Chief Justice
William Rehnquist,
he dissented in
the Grutter case,
arguing that the close parallels
between the percentage of URMs
who applied and the percentage
who were accepted in any given
year, year over year, proved
that the law school was
in fact employing a quota
to reach its critical mass
of racial minorities.
In other words, it was
looking to see-- well,
how many out of the
whole pool applied?
OK, we need to make sure
roughly that many get accepted.
And so, he says, man, this is an
obvious failure of the narrowly
tailored test.
They're not being
treated as individuals.
As for the
undergraduate university
use of race in admissions,
the Gratz v. Bollinger case,
the Supreme Court ruled
that by awarding 20 points
automatically to
every URM applicant,
the University did not treat
them as individual persons,
and therefore they
were using race
in a way that ensured
their acceptance.
Rehnquist wrote the
majority opinion in Gratz,
but he had to follow the
Grutter precedent in order
to reach his conclusion.
And it was a conclusion
that O'Connor joined,
and so that was a
6 to 3 decision.
So to wrap things up
here, Frederick Douglass
devoted his adult life to
getting white Americans,
as he put it, to
trust the operation
of its own principles.
Or as King put it, all
we ask is that you be
true to what you said on paper.
That paper was the
Declaration of Independence
and the Constitution,
which King viewed
as a promissory note to
which every American was
to fall heir.
A colorblind
Constitution would seem
to be a logical implementation
of the colorblind ideals
of the Declaration
of Independence.
But the Supreme
Court essentially
has left us with two
conclusions about government
use of racial classifications
under the Constitution.
Number one, government
can't pay attention to race
when it involves
assigning students
to public schools at the
K through 12 grade levels.
Number two, government
can pay attention to race
if it involves colleges
and graduate schools,
like law schools, and their
exercise of academic freedom
in pursuit of the
educational diversity
that flows from
racial diversity.
In the end, as long as the
Supreme Court continues
to apply a strict scrutiny test
to determine if affirmative
action or any other
race-based program--
whether in college admissions,
hiring and promotion,
or awarding
government contracts--
a colorblind Constitution
is nowhere in sight.